danielle how are we doing my 11 year old
daughter was diagnosed with add in
second grade
we did try her we tried to run some
medication
she didn't do very well with it it
either made her physically ill or just a
totally different
depressed little girl she's very happy
very you know like my little sunshine
girl i call her
but so we're not doing medication now
i've read
gabor mates scatter minds book but i
just need some tangible ways to
encourage her to be more disciplined
without her feeling ashamed of herself
so give me a picture of like what was it
about her
in second grade that made you think uh
oh
something's wrong with my daughter i
need to get her medicated well like
paint paint me
that picture what was going on so she
her teacher brought it up to me and
actually her stepmother too i really
just thought she was just
she she's very she's the life of the
party she's a social butterfly so i just
thought it was
just that's her personality i really
didn't think that she
had add but her stepmother said her
stepmother is a teacher
so she said i think she has this and
then her teacher
also said it um or that you know she's
having trouble focusing she can't
get her or she doesn't get her work done
her handwriting is really sloppy
she's just kind of scattered so
then i took her to the pediatrician and
they have this test i don't even know if
they still do it now but it was
some fda approved test to see if they
had
adhd she's never been hyperactive um
but she but she did you know pat or you
know fail or whatever and they said that
she had add
so then we started the medication and it
just was it was not good
yeah so what do you see in your home
i i love your initial default which was
she's just a life apart this is her
personality we're gonna have some things
that
make her unique and beautiful in her own
way like
bonkers handwriting and man she's gonna
have to really stay on her
what what have you noticed that has made
you think my daughter's broken
okay so she um if she has
well when she does homework i usually
have to sit with her the entire time
uh or she you know she won't finish it
she just spaces out she you know
whatever
if i tell her to go do a task like today
i told her
um pick up the things off your floor
and i usually just try to give her one
task at a time but
it seems lately that even just the one
task she gets distracted before she can
get it done
okay so i said pick up the things off
the floor and then empty your lunch box
and then go
clean your guinea pig's cage so um
she didn't even get to the first one
before she got distracted how does she
do with
um how does she do with lists like if
you sit down with her and say all right
let's make a list of the next three
things you've got to do
and you have a big check mark that would
have included those three things how
does she do with those
she does better with lists but she'll do
the funnest thing
first whatever is the most fun that's
what's gonna you know
happen and then sometimes she forgets to
go back to the list even
okay so i have done that before and it's
it's like
you know she just sometimes doesn't go
back life yeah
so you mentioned um and again i'm gonna
ask these questions not in a
causal blame kind of way can you promise
me that you won't take them there
sure i know it's so hard okay i'm trying
to get a full picture of your daughter
you mentioned she's got a stepmom and so
one of the
tenants of adhd that i just live by is
that it's not a brain disorder
but it's a developmental delay right and
often with their psychological tension
in the home
then that kids start to make sense of
their world
in a chaotic way um so she's from a home
of divorce is that right tell me about
the home she grew up in
so her father and i divorced when she
was two and a half i
think it was yeah two and a half um and
she
she in florida they want it to be kind
of 50 50. her dad lives
on the other side of town so she stays
with me uh 60
of the time and then he gets them some
of the time her dad also has
edd too so um
so i mean we her dad and i didn't like
yell and argue and fight a lot it was
kind of
i guess like a deep like
underlying feeling of stress it was just
kind of it said it's that
yeah kids absorb what i call that low
level tension that just
that it's that third rail that just
buzzes underneath the house at all times
yeah right yeah
children will absorb that and then
obviously the grieving process for both
of you after this is over right
and so here's a couple of important
things and i'll give you some tangible
things here
um super important please please please
let your daughter know she's not broken
and i would have a hard conversation
with stepmom and dad
we are not going to communicate to our
daughter that she's broke in any way
that she
has some sort of thing that is going to
keep her from
having joy or being productive she's
gonna need medication for the rest of
her life
i will tell you right now my childhood
was hard
and i wouldn't trade i'm off the chart
if you were to give me an adhd
test i'm off the chart on it and i
wouldn't trade
anything for it nothing
because of the creativity the way i
solve problems all of that stuff
and i have to be highly intentional
about surrounding myself with a team of
people that keeps me accountable
um just today on this show james was
saying
before he started the show you have one
minute and i'm pushing start on the
record button right like we're gonna do
this right
and so um i do have a group of people
who will hold me accountable for being
on time which i struggle with because i
love just talking to people
being in relationship with folks i do
have folks that
that work with me on a task list and
this is stuff i've had to grow up and
learn how to do and it's hard and it's
challenging
but i wouldn't trade it for the world
okay and so i
don't want your daughter growing up
thinking she's deficient
busted broken not like everybody else or
anything like that
your initial response that core thing
that came out of you which was
look at our unique daughter look what
she brings to the world and to each
social interaction she's involved in
that's a kind of spirit and so what i
tell parents often
is this is a context not an excuse
okay you have a you have a picture great
you still got to clean your room right
right so there's a balance between
going to war with a kid and coming up
with strategies that are going to help
them
be successful so what i've seen highly
successful
in my own personal life and with kids
that i've worked closely with
and with families is breaking tasks up
into bite-sized chunks especially for
young kids is a big deal
holding out the um like the fun one
you're gonna do these two and then the
fun one and then i'm gonna give you this
card and then we're gonna set the timer
and i'm gonna come check on you in 10
minutes
this is going to be harder for you for
the next couple of years for both you
and your husband and stepmom right or if
your ex husband and stepmom y'all gonna
have to lean in and so
with one of your kids you might be able
to say hey go clean your room and
they're gonna come back in 30 minutes um
i found it helpful to walk into a room
and say all right we're just doing shoes
now when all the shoes are up come back
and find me
and they it may come back in three
minutes they make one in 30 minutes
and i'm gonna go check on them so it's
breaking up
um jobs and bite-sized chunks and here's
what we're looking for we're looking for
little wins
we're looking for little successes to
build on not a cumulative amount of
failures to point out does that make
sense
okay um a a phrase that
guides my life is this don't forget to
remember
and i took that from dr mate but don't
forget to remember
and so often kids who are experiencing
this symptomology of adhd
they will walk through a room and they
won't see their clothes on the floor and
they won't
they just literally are are not
processing it right they're just running
right to the next thing
but you know what they know they know
feelings and they know how good it feels
when the room is clean
and so i will get out of my truck and
there'll be seven glasses in my truck
when i get home i don't know where they
come from they seem to grow in my car
uh but i will go start my truck in the
winter and then i'll put a cup of coffee
in there and then i'll run upstairs and
be like i need to get some coffee before
i leave the house and i'll come down
with another one i'll have two and then
i'll drink them both on the way to work
and then i'll come out of work and i'll
have two i don't know where they all
come from
but here here's the thing i remember how
good it feels when my truck is clean
when i get it in the morning
and so every night i remember how good
it's going to feel tomorrow and
for whatever reason that fuels me that
gets me to stop what i'm doing i know
how good it feels when i have that
little thing i put over my windshield
and it's not covered in ice right so
don't forget to remember so if you point
out
feelings not failures for a kid who's
struggling in this way
remember how good it feels when you do
the fun thing remember how good it feels
when all of your clothes are picked up
i want you just to get your dresses and
then come back and find me and just get
your tennis shoes and then come back and
find me and we're gonna celebrate those
little wins
and you mom are gonna get exhausted okay
you're gonna it's such a beating you
just wanna go do your thing right
and it's gonna be hard um the you're
teaching
her how to have little wins in her life
and these are going to pay off big time
down the road
a couple of other things um is exercise
is
huge okay and we often think of
exercises burning off energy it's not
it's a it's a way to get different
chemicals
pulsing through the young young body
okay and it's good for her
it's good for you and that could be
walking and when y'all go on walks
together hold hands
make sure she's getting physical touch
from you and make sure that you have
skin-to-skin contact with her as much as
humanly possible make sure your husband
is doing that as well
and i'm talking about kind of obnoxious
amounts like i'm just gonna hold your
face for a second and this is super
weird and i'm your mom and i'm gonna be
super weird and you're gonna just have
to get over it
and she'll go mom this is so weird and
you'll be like i'm just a weird mom i'm
going to hold your face
and you're going to look at me in the
eyes you're going to count my um the
little
creases in my eyes count my wrinkles i
dare you right
something like that but i want her to
start
consciously getting skin to skin contact
and
eye contact and then sleep is
major okay and sleep can be wartime for
kids that are struggling with this
but a sleep routine that no matter what
is going on ever
ever ever stick to that routine and
something about a kid's brain that has
sleep just slowly over time turns those
alarms off
okay schools i think are almost
borderline criminal for how early they
make kids get up
how early they um how much work they
give these kids in the evening time
and they got kids going to bed at ten
o'clock and getting up at five o'clock
to be at school by 6 45
it's it's literally insane what we're
doing to these children's brains
and that may mean that you have to put
your like start getting ready for bed at
7 30
and you're gonna feel weird um and then
have your kid in bed no later that eight
o'clock
7 30. we do real early bedtimes in our
house
um as you can imagine my kids they look
a lot like their dad
and sleep is everything a couple other
things play with your kid
like play like hey let's you may have
heard me earlier talking about
do silly things like if you've got um
you know
go outside and play catch with the
tennis ball have water fights
but tangible things that they can touch
back to
i'm normal and i'm laughing and mom's
normal and she's laughing and we're all
doing stuff together
nature walking around outside barefoot
some of these things that are going to
sound really
weird and not like like kooky try them
out for 30 days
and i almost guarantee you that your kid
will
have a reorientation to you and to just
a more
peace right peace and if it's about
connection with your kid if it's about
playing with your kid if it's about
joy with your kid and not about what
they didn't do
those alarms in her heart and mine can
start to slow down and quiet a little
bit
which then of course gives her an
opportunity to be a little bit more
successful with cleaning up
a little bit more successful with seeing
what how good that feels when she gets
something done
and so on and so on and so forth and
this is
going to be hard for you can i tell you
one more thing for you
please i want you to forgive yourself
and carry no
baggage about this in your own heart
okay
okay will you promise me that
yeah moms and dads absolutely beat
themselves up
for this parents who get divorced
absolutely beat themselves up for this
stuff
and what i'll tell you is that tension
that you
feel that shame that you feel that hurt
inside you that you feel
she absorbs that and she blames herself
for that feeling and tries to fix it
okay and so i want you just to be at
peace this is what it is your daughter's
beautiful sounds like she's fun she's
gonna be hilarious to me the life of the
party
she's gonna be an awesome person to be
employed by and she's gonna have to have
a really killer admin assistant that
keeps her on track right
that's the way she's gonna that's the
way it's gonna work and she is gonna
um have to learn some skills and mom
can't be calling her at college saying
did you do your homework she's gonna
have to learn how to fail
and she's gonna have to learn that mom's
not gonna pay for college when she fails
and so she's got to figure it out and
she will
right especially if you start these
connection
practices now i also want you to be
super graceful with her in this season
i don't know a single kid in the united
states of america that's not struggling
right now kovit has been a train wreck
on these poor kids and they've been
locked in front of screens they've had
weird associations even when they're at
school they're wearing masks it's just
been a mess
and so every signaling receptor system a
kid has
which is eye contact face contact
watching people's mouths laughing
shoving each other in the hallways all
those things
all that's gone away overnight and so if
you have a kid who leans towards being a
little bit hyperactive
if you have a a young girl who's
hyperactive which sometimes looks like
they shut down man this is just
messes with them it just melt melted
them so be graceful too
um and i'll just tell you your
daughter's lucky to have you man
i love love love hearing from my mom hey
i read about it i'm learning about it
what are some tangible things so
do that for 30 days i'd love please
please please call me back danielle let
me know how this is going i'd love to
know how
um how your daughter's doing after 30
days of intense
intense sleep man movement
little little wins and a lot of contact
from mom
and mom forgiving herself and dropping
that brick of shame and
moving on and being joyful too that's
awesome